welcome to another video of key cultures
tips and tricks for the brand new razer
phone 2
and as you can see here we have the
brand new razer phone
and not many people realize that on
default once you get the phone out of
the box you do need to actually
tweak some settings in order to get the
phone back up to
120 hertz
which is the main draw of the race of
one after all first thing you need to do
is to head on down to the display of the
phone
and go into settings and you can see
that
the refresh rate of the phone is
actually tweaked at 90 hertz
click that and you have a few options
things not focusing so well but here you
go
it's pretty hard to actually pick up the
difference so
how 120 hertz looks like compared to
other phones but this is a good peak of
what you should expect
it's very nice and snappy when it comes
to scrolling and
let's say we look at photos
very nice and smooth as you go through
the photos itself
and that's pretty much it when it comes
to
the
razer phone 2 and getting the 120 hertz